grace is with us in Chicago hi grace
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi hi
what's up in your world well I've got a
problem with well it's not my problem my
son is going with a girl he's living
with a girl right now and they want to
buy a house together and I already have
a problem with them living together and
I know I've heard you say things about
the financial problem sex would come up
if unmarried couples get a mortgage
together when I was funny if you could
explain those to me maybe maybe I can
convince him that way that this might
not be a good idea without getting
married first I completely agree with
you
the yeah it's a disaster to buy a home
with someone that you're not married to
it's an absolute disaster because there
you have no legal control over the
process if this doesn't work out and so
basically what you're doing is from a
legal standpoint you're forming a
general partnership and so if if she was
she leaves he's stuck with the whole
thing oh by the way he can't sell it
because he doesn't own it by himself so
if she just takes off to Alaska or
wherever which happens all the time in
these situations then he can't sell the
house to get out of the mortgage that he
is on because he's not the only owner
you have to have the other owners
signature and so you would have to put
together I mean the only reasonable
legal way to put it together would be a
detailed in-depth partnership agreement
from a legal standpoint that says what
happens if you break up it says what
happens if someone dies it says what
happens if someone becomes disabled it
says what happens because all of those
things are handled if you happen to be
married that's more that's all that's
all kind of pretty much handled then at
least there's a mechanism if everything
falls apart called divorce which would
be sad and we certainly don't want to
plan for that but at least you've got
that
to figure out how a judge can then you
know determine the assets and how
they're broken up and so forth the other
way is just it never works so you know I
would just beg people that are living
together to not buy a house together it
really I have never run into a situation
where it works out good
it always has ends up being the end of a
bad story and it's always complicates
bad enough to get your heart broken it's
bad enough to go through a relationship
like that and then have a split it's bad
enough to go through a relationship like
that and have some sad thing happened
like disability or death but that that's
all bad enough but I add to that a house
in the middle of it that you're stuck in
now it just makes the whole thing really
nasty please don't let them do this I
hope I can convince them but you know
they're in love and I know it will be
difficult for them to even think of you
know a separation later on yeah I'm not
even questioning love that's not the
question the question is stupid
and this is just I mean let's pretend
they weren't in love if it was to to get
two buddies wanting to buy a house
together don't do it I want my room man
I'm gonna buy a house with my roommate
no bad idea
really really really bad idea
listen homeowners up a good thing no
homeownership is a curse if you do it
wrong and this is the Deaf one of the
definitions of wrong so I I think the
challenge you might have is you've
probably already said enough about them
living together right yes and so you
probably have lost your some of your
influence in the conversation because
this is what I'm dealing with here is is
not just I mean the moral aspect I agree
with you on and that's the side issue
but that there's a legal and financial
and structural disaster here this is not
you know you can't act like you're
married when you're not in the legal
world it just doesn't work now for you
you know I mean that's it's hey you buy
a dog together you know I mean because
the poor dog ends up in a problem it's
just it's
man I had bad bad bad bad so I think you
know it if you somehow in the discussion
can separate the this from just the
legal and the transactional mess that
this is going to represent and separate
that from the moral discussion of living
together maybe you can speak into this
situation but you may have been like me
you may have already said so much you
don't have the right anymore because
they're not listening anything you say
anymore
it could have happened I sure hope you
can talk them out of it though
you